Prime Minister are you still seriously
saying that you have met in full your
manifesto commitment specifically on
child benefits and this four year but
I'm very happy to be judged we on what
we set out in our manifesto and what
we've achieved because we set out some
important goals that we wanted to
restrict welfare and we have we wanted
to cut bureaucracy and we will we wanted
to ensure fairness for countries outside
the eurozone and we will and we want to
get out of ever closer Union Europe for
us is about cooperation and trade and
working together for our prosperity and
security it's not about a political
union and we've made I think huge
progress on all those issues have we
solved all your problems no have we
solved all of Britain's problems with
Europe no but this is a much better
basis for us to put a referendum to the
British public on you set a couple of
things as totemic symbolic issues that
you wanted to achieve one of those was a
complete bar for four years for in work
migrant access to in work benefits you
didn't get that you've got a limitation
instead that is not fulfilling your
manifesto people said you will never get
a four-year ban at all will always be
this manifesto media my political
opponents said it people that wanted to
leave the EU come what may he said it
and we have achieved no more something
for nothing you can't come to Britain
and get instant access to our welfare
system and it's going to take you four
years before you get full access now I'm
happy to be judged on that not just
because of the effect on migration I
think he goes to a deeper value which is
people in our country and me too quite
rightly say if you come to Britain to
work hard good but you are put in before
you take out you change the goalposts
though because you never said something
for nothing it wasn't in your speech on
November the 10th there wasn't in your
letter to Donald Tusk this is a new
threshold the whole election campaign
was no more something for nothing in
fact the whole idea back in 2010 was
that we needed a system where it pays to
work rather than be on welfare where if
you work you get rewards because we cut
your taxes no more something-for-nothing
is a very large part of my entire
political philosophy ok on child
benefits very clear in your manifesto
you know I've got the page here page 30
no child benefit exported to EU migrants
of their children abroad
you haven't got that why not say I've
got 70% of what I want 80% right the
city is a negotiation but I'm happy as I
say to be judged by what we put in our
manifesto and what we're achieving on
things that people previous said it's
just we're not gonna make progress on
you won't get anywhere on this stuff and
onch
you know basically I set out for things
if you come to Britain you won't get
unemployment benefit sorted
secondly if you don't have a job after
six months you've got to go home
sorted third no child benefit were
little bit child benefit but sent home
at a local rate and forth four years
before access to our welfare system well
it's four years until full access to our
welfare system I would say judge me on
those things they are substantial
they're meaningful they're not the final
word but I think they do make a
difference particularly on this key
value that we don't believe in something
for nothing if you come to Britain work
hard that's great but you are put in
before you get out you've seen the
reaction of newspapers this morning we
had a poll out showing 69% of people
thought that it was a bad deal 44%
people said it was they'd be less likely
to vote to stay in from what they've
heard about what you've achieved you've
got to do a lot harder to win over the
public on this front do you not on the
quality of the deal well I think first
of all there are the issues that
Britain's had the biggest trouble with
in Europe and that's because it's too
bureaucratic it's too much of a
political union there's not a fairness
between eurozone countries and
non-eurozone countries and also the
problems of migration all those four
issues are addressed to an extent by the
negotiations that work we look like we
will be able to achieve with further
hard work but of course at the end of
that we then go to a an even bigger
picture which is how will Britain best
succeed in the future and I'm not
arguing Britain can't succeed outside
the EU of course we can we're an amazing
country with a 5th largest economy in
the world the question is going to be
the big question are we safer will we
have more jobs more prosperity will be
more successful in this reform Europe or
out that will be the big question right
look forward to making those arguments
in terms of managing some the tensions
in your cabinet surely if you turn
around recommend this deal on the basis
of economic and national security and
someone disagrees with your judgment as
Prime Minister on those issues how can
you let them back in to back
to cabinet cause Europe is an issue that
raises great passions and some people
have very long-standing views that
Britain would be better off outside the
EU and I don't want to say that those
people can't serve in a in a cabinet of
mine so the sensible thing to do is for
the whole government to pursue this
renegotiation get the best possible
terms that we can and then say to the
British public here's the job is to stay
in on these change terms or leave and
allow those cabinet ministers who want
to be on the leave side to make those
arguments I think you know to argue to
pretend that businesses or families or
political parties or you know all have
to be on the same side of this I think
is right that's one question Syria
that's great thank you so big summits
for you tomorrow this funding conference
what are you hoping to achieve from
money alone and shouldn't the Arab
countries really step up for a problem
in their neighborhood well I think there
are three things we want to achieve
first is a major advance in terms of
funds for the UN programs and this is so
important this is food for refugees it's
shelter for refugees it's making sure
that in those refugee camps and in the
neighboring countries people can be
properly looked after and I want us to
do a lot better this year than last year
and I think we will second is education
let's make sure that we don't have
refugee children in the region or else
we're not in school by the end of the
next academic year I think that's
absolutely vital
third and creatively you were trying to
help those people in the region who
would like to stay there and work and
provide for their families because of
course people's first choice would be to
go back to Syria they can't do that at
the moment their second choice is
probably to stay in the region but to
provide for their children that are
helping them to do that with more work
permits is something we're looking at